great workout with Jordan he taught me
some stuff now making changes and stuff
me and Gary be up in the office whoever
will be to corporate talk about
ownership and leverage API detectors
that out of those anniversary step one
find a place that sells stuff under
priced to Internet marketplaces this
place
step two go into the store and find the
toy section where is it step three make
Jordan download the eBay app Amazon -
but oh there's a toy section see it step
4
start looking at all the random toy
stuff and look for stuff like Star Wars
gives me or something that people give a
[ __ ] about alright we found our first
one 50% off is the good dinosaur 99 5
bucks looks like there might be a couple
more in here let's look it up a big fan
of little items I think we might have
nailed something here you guys can see
these are $2.99 a pop right and if
there's a bunch there's some more boxes
up here I think that has cases of it
so a lot of all you
if you look carefully I've been showing
you sold results by Jordan just learned
that lesson you see things worth it like
your euros that your these are listed
all day at 70 bucks a pop which would
have been great at a dollar mine but
because we didn't told not as good we'll
do books another day the books or
gangster on Amazon like an Oprah book
telling you thanks guys it's not for
everybody because it really comes down
to how valuable your time is but for the
people that are really looking for two
or three or four hundred dollars more a
month it's just really sitting there in
so many stores goodwill garage sales job
lot
[Music]